5 25 on your wednesday morning we have
viewers responding to an earlier email
where a guy was talking about drivers on
the 215 beltway should not be going 65
in the far left lane
victor had written if you want to drive
at the speed limit stay in the center
lane blocking faster drivers doesn't
make it safer well now we hear from
carol it's true that that is the passing
lane but it's also true that 65 miles an
hour is the speed limit shouldn't be
passing someone who's already driving
the speed limit and dale if my speed
bothers you because you're breaking the
law and can't manage your time
that's your problem not mine
oh boy well i would hope that we can all
agree that speeding is a problem no
matter where you're driving no matter
what lane you're in and that too many
people are dying on our roads the
question remains how do we reach the
people that really need to hear all this
we're talking about the ones for whom
the news is not part of their world i'd
love to hear your ideas buckle up drive
carefully please put down that phone
something's driving you crazy here's the
email address traffic eight at eight
newsnow dot com